Now there's another great way you can track down information about this.
If you go back to the Profiles tab, you can actually take a
heap snapshot. Now what the heap snapshot is going to do is actual
going to give you a listing of everything that's been allocated up to this
snapshot in time. Of course, this really doesn't help you because it
actually lists a lot of system-level resources that have been allocated as well.
What you need to do is actually take a second heap snapshot.
Now, when you take these two half snapshots you can actually go down
here to the bottom where it says all objects and
instead set this to show objects allocated between those two snapshots.
Now this is going to tell you only the objects that
were actually created in memory between clicking that button. Now if
you remember before we showed that saw tooth pattern, inside
of the time line view. Which basically told us that memory
was being allocated even though I was going nothing. And with
our two snapshots you can see that same principle occurs here,
that about 612 bytes were allocated between the three seconds
it took me to take two snapshots. If we drill down
into some of the objects here you can see that
a bunch of numbers were actually created. Most importantly you can
see in the call stack, that these are x objects.
So it looks like some velocity has been changed, right? You
can see velocity here, velocity.x. So somewhere in our little
application, the x property of the velocity object was actually created.
Clicking on the Objects tab actually shows us the
same thing. We can see an object was created with
a value of x and a type of number for
some sort of proto-object. Now playing around between a heap
timeline and heap snapshot, gives you an amazing amount
of visibility into how memory is being used in your
web application. Remember, follow the memory, find your performance problems.
Listen, you want to know more about performance. You want to get
your application running fast and smooth and junk free
so that your users don't have to complain about it,
follow the tips I've detailed and most importantly, follow
the perfmatters hash tag on your favorite social media network.
There's a lot of extremely smart people out there,
all trying to handle these problems in very important ways.
Following this hash tag is going to key you in
to how they're thinking and how they're solving the problems.